so the no good very bad week for the FBI
just got worse less than 72 hours after
the Durham report revealed and
discovered and proved that the bureau
was biased against former president
Trump a group of FBI whistleblowers
giving explosive testimony on Capitol
Hill the witnesses accusing the agency
of unfair treatment and alleging
retaliation Republicans say this is just
further proof of what it calls
institutional rot and anti-conservative
bias and adding to their argument just
before the hearing the FBI yanked
security clearances of two of the agents
working as an FBI special agent was my
dream job
my whistleblowing was apolitical and in
the spirit of upholding my oath
nonetheless the FBI cynically elected to
close ranks and attack the messenger my
family and I have been surviving on
early withdrawals from our retirement
accounts while the FBI has ignored my
request for approval to obtain outside
employment I never sworn off to the FBI
I sworn off to the Constitution do you
believe that the FBI is purposefully
hostile to you for that reason to keep
Agents from speaking up yes yes that
question yes
chairman Jim Jordan warning the
whistleblowers that they would face
heavy attacks from Democrats
we've talked to over two dozen
whistleblowers
people have come to us we've interviewed
several of those and today three of them
three of those Brave whistleblowers and
a lawyer who represents them will tell
us their story
they will tell us what happened what
they saw and then what happened to them
because they were courageous enough to
report it to Congress
and I just want to tell you guys
get ready
get ready because these guys are going
to come after you
you know they are well Jordan was
definitely on to something Democrats did
Bash Republicans for even holding the
hearing and trying to undermine The
credibility of whistleblowers
on Police Week watching House
Republicans jump to lay the foundation
to defund law enforcement
my colleagues on the far right are on a
mission to attack discredit and
ultimately dismantle the FBI
this is defund the police on steroids
you're engaging in the self-promotion of
your new book that's about to be
released and what great timing to be on
TV and in Congress right before your
book tour starts in Texas we would just
say that this is just a lot of hot air
blowing here and it ain't a
whistleblower
this is one of the most heated
passionate hearings I have seen on
Capitol Hill in a long time as we
watched the whole thing this morning the
both sides came loaded for bear Jesse
get your initial thoughts the primary
allegation was that there was a cash
incentive program with the FBI so the
more investigations a field office opens
up the more cash bonuses are given to
the head of the field office so that's
why you're seeing this flurry of
Investigations a flurry of arrests
that's why so many January 6
prosecutions so many parents are being
investigated Catholics are now being
investigated and it explains why anybody
who even went to DC on January 6th was
investigated they were investigated for
money but they were investigated and
Bank of America handed over to the FBI
every single transaction that was made
by people that flew into DC for January
6. not only that the FBI was taking
officers off child porn cases and making
them hang out in the parking lots of
parent-teacher conferences and write
down their license plates they made the
Betsy Ross flag or a bumper sticker that
said 2A a terror symbol so now you
understand why the FBI says white
supremacy is the number one threat in
the country because it's a predominantly
white country and you could make money a
fortune investigating everything a flag
waiver a small business owner a trump
supporter a parent anybody that can be
considered
wait you can open up an investigation
and get paid for that so it's a very
perverse incentive and then they got
retaliated against because they tried to
blow the whistle correctly up the chain
of command and then they like sent them
to California and then locked all their
belongings in a storage unit and one
family FBI family was left homeless for
a week and they said the FBI will crush
you if you speak out against them and
that's why a lot of people are saying
the FBI needs to be dismantled you'll
have more tonight do these
whistleblowers and Jim Gordon tonight at
seven don't say I never promote your
show thank you because I will always do
it I will always do it judge
um you know it's interesting not only
did they bump up these cash bonuses and
we remember remember with the Veterans
Administration they they pumped up the
numbers and said they were doing these
great jobs when they really weren't
helping veterans but they made these
fake stats so that they could make more
money whenever you put money in with the
federal government you're making a
mistake they based on the numbers of
cases or bonuses for for arrests or
callers it's just it's inconsistent it's
a bad intersection but it's worse than
that because what they did was they
pumped up the numbers not just for the
money but if they were doing something
that they called a white supremacist
investigation and they had four people
they were interviewing it wasn't the one
case it was then four cases so they
could bump up the stats and say Yes
white supremacy it's the biggest problem
in America today and what they did to
these whistleblowers is really it's it's
frightening because there by the way
there's a whistleblower protection act I
have no faith in it to be honest with
you but what they did to these people to
these FBI agents and you know it's the
the main FBI agents you know the middle
wrong of them they're doing a great job
they believe in this country they're
taking care to make sure that they
follow all the rules and regulations
it's the upper core of the FBI that is
corrupt that's been politicized that has
been weaponized and so they take these
little people so to speak and they made
him homeless they made one guy actually
move his family to another town he and
then forced him to relocate and then as
soon as he got there they put him on
unpaid indefinite suspension and he's
homeless I mean this is the FBI at its
worst but we already knew that and and
one more thing the the congresswoman I
think her name is uh Plaskett uh she is
from Stacy Plaskett yeah Casey Plaskett
uh she talks about how this is defund
police on steroids are you kidding me we
had uh the uh Horowitz investigation
where Horowitz said the FBI was
basically not doing its job that Jim
Comey was you know someone who lied and
the the uh uh the affidavit was
unverified and went on and on and then
you have the Durham report saying that
the FBI failed to uphold its mission to
Fidelity to the law and this woman
labels these people as people who want
to defund the police the Republicans and
and finally it is it is simply too easy
to say that a whistleblower who is
saying something that is against his own
interest it's too easy for them to say
you know what they're really inept they
were bad at their job because how do you
fight this system how do you fight the
institution of the FBI you can't so the
incentive is against someone who wants
to be a whistleblower and uh this is a
perfect example of it one of the things
that was revealed today that guess what
wasn't revealed to me because I didn't
know that the Whistleblower protections
for FBI employees and agents is
different from the rest of the federal
government which is something that could
perhaps be looked at to by the Congress
Harold Ford Jr the Democrats came ready
today they've got some pretty strong
members on their side as well they do
it's good to be back a couple of things
um I think the report the Durham report
is a troubling troubling thing whenever
the the people the American people lose
confidence in a federal agency
particularly a law enforcement agency or
have reason to I Mr Durham uncovered a
lot of that uh that that's something we
need to take very seriously and I would
hope that the committee might take a
look and if I were chairman Jordan I
would invite uh director Ray who was
actually praised in the report by Mr
Durham saying he was taking big efforts
to clean up some of the investigative
excesses uh to give him a sense of what
they've really done and I think they
could probably explore the whistle The
Whistleblower protections for FBI agents
two there's been politics in every
agency the Department of Defense
Education ATF the FBI every acronym
there is
IRS they've been ours and D's forever
and it probably is a little bias uh
somewhere along the way I think
whistleblower should be protected in
every agency and one of the things that
has to be done is you have to
corroborate their stories uh and while
you corroborate their stories they
should not be punished and it sounds as
if at least from some of the testimony
you can read into that maybe they're
those who believe who the whistleblowers
believe that they have been retaliated
against if I were chairman Jordan I'd
call in those and I would ask the most
the blowers do will you sign a document
that said we can look at your your
employee employee file because these are
serious serious allegations now I I
don't like engaging in Republicans are
so bad they're coming after Democrats I
thought it was a little responsible the
chairman to do those things to make that
statement but if he has the evidence to
back it up then he should he should he
should put forth uh the evidence a close
where I started I give Dr director Ray a
lot more credit than than perhaps some
not around this table but some are in
the in the in the in the Press he did a
lot to clean this up and if you don't
believe it Durham says it in his own
report I hope the FBI gets back to doing
what they do best which is protecting us
against domestic and foreign crimes and
threats and get back to the great work
they did in Idaho where they were able
to hunt down that guy that killed those
four people that's you know it's
interesting that was one of the things I
was going to ask you about Tom is that
in the Whistleblower testimony one of
the concerns that they said they had is
that all of this focus on domestic
terrorism has really taken our eye off
the ball from foreign enemies and
terrorism I mean it's unbelievable and
that we're back to like a September 10th
attitude we've seen it and we've seen
him doing these raids and knocking on
doors with the pro-life demonstrators
and things like that investigating
Catholics and other issues like that
it's obviously rotten and I said to my
friend the other day I said something it
kind of bothered him I said they're
going to get away with it because they
broke the law legally he said what are
you talking about how do you do that I
say they broke the law legally like
we've seen it it dramatized on
television shows like the wire where you
have the mob a lawyer who's doing work
for a drug dealer and we watched the way
that he worked he used the law to his
advantage to essentially make this drug
dealer legitimate but he was a drug
dealer he was selling drugs to children
that's what this lawyer was doing but
you can't get him on it that's the way
guys like Comey and uh McCabe operated
they knew they were Above the Law
because they know what the law is I
think they broke the law I don't like
the word bias they broke the law legally
now the whistleblowers might be able to
uncover some things I don't think
they're going to get the guys at the top
but some heads may be able to roll when
you get these guys who are on the inside
giving information it is interesting
that the cat apparently has James
comey's tongue he used to love the media
damn I didn't find him anywhere I've
been looking can I say one thing for all
the the compliments that Christopher Ray
is getting who did he let go he came in
right after James Comey the straw McCabe
and the rest of them what is Christopher
Ray done other than say you know I'm
gonna do better
I mean you can't well you can cherry
pick the report if you want but all
right all right all right I want to
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube
or that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now